the owner of mac's public house in
staten island new york who said he'd
rather go to jail than close his doors
because it would be for good
is still refusing to back down his story
inspired hundreds
thousands i would say to show up and
protest for him
about the city's lockdown that's coming
our way sending the message they stand
with him and all the others fighting to
save their livelihoods while being
responsible
danny presti uh two days out of uh uh
two days after his arrest uh joins us
now
danny max is still closed how are you
going to get it open
and what is the game plan from here
so in the next couple days max will be
open
we're working on that and right now
we're sitting down with our legal team
and we're trying to at this point work
with the city we've pleaded with them
um to work with us and other small
businesses at this point just like i
said in the beginning
we are losing faith and kind of lost
faith in
the ability for our local and city
governments to help us
the immediate local governments are
helping us those officials
but the governor and the mayor seem like
they don't want anything so at some
point if they don't give us
assistance in some way or are working
with us to get
things back open again in a safe manner
um we're gonna have to take things into
our own hands
so we've actually been in contact with
ian smith
um from attila's gym in del mar new
jersey
and together we're creating a united
front
we're setting up the infrastructure and
what we're trying to do is get the
resources for all businesses that want
to stay open
to remain open and we're going to give
them
all the information and even other
people and
not including small businesses um just
people that want to show support and
help
um the information will be available for
them as well just justify the order
here's what governor cuomo said he said
this owner is learning that actions have
consequences breaking the law and
putting your neighbors
lives at risk during a global pandemic
to make a political statement is simply
unacceptable
what is he talking about political
statement all you want to do is earn a
living
what political statement are you making
yep and that's exactly it and
um you know we'd like to take politics
out of it but they seem to creep into
everything no matter what
we just need in some way to either be
assisted
or to get our places open and these
state agencies and city agencies that
come in
and threaten to find us or pull our
licenses every single day
it's not right and these agencies should
be coming in and assisting us and saying
how can we help you
and what support do you need and if you
need any information we're here to help
you
instead we have these the state liquor
authority
and the tsa and all these agencies
kicking open the door and then
threatening
tens of thousands of fines every day and
i'm getting calls from all these small
businesses saying what can we do and
this is what we're saying to our
governments
and governor cuomo and the mayor is you
have to stop this and you need to assist
us
but he's not if you can't because he
assists us use these agencies
you're forgetting this governor is an
egomaniac he is an emmy award winner
he loves celebrities he loves himself he
loves to hear himself talk
and he has no interest in your business
uh sadly but we do
and i hope you keep fighting because
you're doing things responsibly
they're letting bars open a few blocks
away from you but they shut you down
because of a zip code as if the virus
knows
a zip code it's ridiculous danny thanks
so much keep fighting
thanks for having me on and we will